when I found out I would say jv+
I wasn't upset I was terrified saying I
have HIV is something big it changes
your life
taking our enteral treatments is not a
desired option they have all their side
effects on our body functions they're
very expensive that is especially
limiting in resource-poor settings of
course take for instance let's out over
25 dollars are assigned per person per
year for healthcare you can imagine that
adequate care for HIV infection stuff
absolutely impossible but there may now
be an alternative medical researchers
have developed a therapeutic vaccine
that could defeat HIV unlike
conventional vaccines which prevent
disease a therapeutic vaccine helps
equip infected bodies to defeat a
disease that's already being contracted
around 1% of the population have innate
immunity to HIV their bodies can fight
the disease without the need for drugs
we wanted to help people to become this
normally only 1% that can deal with the
infection without taking drugs and so
what we wanted to achieve is really what
we call a functional cure a functional
cure is where the patient doesn't suffer
any of the problems associated with HIV
but there may still be traces of the
virus in his or her system HIV infects
some of the persons white blood cells
that normally help protect the body
against illness once the immune system
is compromised an infected person is at
risk of dying from such diseases
tuberculosis pneumonia or the flu HIV is
so hard to treat because it is usually
hidden from the body's own defense
system in otherwise healthy looking
cells to kill it requires a two-step
process firstly the vaccine boosts a
patient's immune system so it is better
able to fight the virus then the patient
is given a drug called Romi leptin which
causes the HIV infected white blood
cells to release proteins on their
surfaces identifying them to the body
the patient's white blood cells boosted
by the vaccine are thus able to find and
destroy these HIV infected cells a group
of scientists ran trials of the vaccine
on 13 people who had recently contracted
HIV with the aim of helping their immune
systems find HIV infected cells and
destroy them once the patients received
the vaccine they stopped taking their
antiretroviral treatment and began
taking Roma Jepson to see whether their
immune systems could defeat the disease
and the results were encouraging five
out of 213 individuals can control the
virus for this forty percent of the
trials participants it's been
life-changing including patient afi's
when I was first told that the treatment
had worked and it was undetectable it
was brilliant since I have had the
vaccine I haven't had to take any pills
or any meds for six months
[Music]
it's not a complete cure so everything
is fine I'm thrilled I don't know what
side effects I might have from taking
this treatment I'm thrilled but I'm
always expecting worse
over the next years we will see
certainly a number of trials of
therapeutic vaccinations going on here
and many other places in the world
we need to hope that we can induce a
functional cure in a large proportion of
these individuals and take them off on
terrestrial treatment but this does not
mean we have won against HIV and we have
a dedicated that virus from the face of
the earth these people are still
infected the challenge is to really
achieve eradication of the virus and
only then can we start thinking of
getting rid of HIV are making it in
history
[Music]